you know what I think we'd actually
become okay have you seen that guy
that's like trying to like reverse his
biological age
isn't that just all of them no no this
guy is special okay he is special that's
not very nice dude
[Laughter]
he's a special guy okay all right well
that's not really nice either I'm not
saying anything about that okay all
right what's that
you know
this guy right here
45 year old Brian Johnson is dedicated
to living longer and by longer I mean
far outpacing the rest of us by
reversing the natural process of Aging
oh let's get it he's already
biologically at least five years younger
than his age according to his team of
doctors
this guy is like freaks me out man does
he have a tick tock or anything
he's got this like program like you can
follow kind of what he does I think you
need a lot of money to do it yeah and
it's anal as [__] yeah like literally
yeah
it's anal so basically to be younger
everything is a suppository yeah and
part of it is Brian has to come in your
ass
Jesus Christ
that's dark as hell
yeah I want to be younger that's what he
said about my butthole but hey
[Laughter]
Noel so thank you so glad you could join
the program Jesus that's dark as hell
so go to
go to YouTube I think he just did an
interview with someone it's definitely
working he looks five right
yeah he looks like a little buddy he
kind of looks like he went too far A
little bit
it's like wait I can't stop it yeah I'm
trying to reverse my age I just want to
be 14 he comes a baby yeah that that one
right there
he spent two thousand dollars I think
this guy like follows him around two
million yeah sorry what did I say two
thousand
uh a minute
two thousand dollars a minute
you know what's so funny is he can
reverse his aging but like he'll
if his mind is still from like born in
1970 or some [__]
imagine the dude looking like you know
dude walks into a party looks like Noah
Beck he looks you know age-appropriate
like 21-22 and he just starts dancing
and he can't dance for [__] like he just
horrifically bad or he just starts
talking about you know like
geopolitics yeah socioeconomic issues
dude how old are you yeah yeah oh you
know this is a this reminds me of Music
around the time like when uh you know
like Vietnam was a thing yeah yeah
how old are you dude oh I'm 58 yeah what
the hell
so fast forward I think we should
actually watch some of this because I
saw some clips yeah and it was so
uncomfortable let's let it rip we've
dramatically slowed my speed of Aging
I'm now aging at a rate slower than the
average 10 year old I'm now aging rate
slower than the average 10 year old
we've been able to do that with just two
years no sorry I'm just like chewing on
that mentally because I have a 68 year
old brain
our brains are aging way faster yeah
yeah than the average person so yeah
does the average 10 year old age slowly
is that no it would be aging very
quickly but he's slowed it down
he's aging
slower than the average 10 year old
so wouldn't that yeah so that wouldn't
really mean that much
that's that's something don't age that
quickly
yeah wrong right yeah yeah you're
ramping up for puberty man yeah that's
true you're getting old yeah
you're playing around it's reasonable
for us to say what can we be in 20 years
it's a cool question it's no longer like
well I probably won't be able to walk
anymore my knees will probably be giving
out and my back will probably hurt we
don't have to make those assumptions
anymore he always thinks he looks old as
[__] so what'd you say I was gonna say
it I was gonna say it it does not look
like you said 45 or whatever the [__] or
they say he looks 55 I'm like yeah he
looks 55. yeah
he's ripped for 55 years he's definitely
jacked yeah but I think it's because he
barely eats anything people just think
this food is good this food is bad going
a little deeper is having specific diets
and that's where you get all these
people debating about paleo versus vegan
that's discountable going another level
deeper is looking at the actual studies
but you still see a lot of things that
are confusing or just conflicting for
example you can feel great on a keto
diet but if you have a certain genetic
predisposition to alzheimer's it
increases your risk by multitudes and as
you go even deeper it's more about hey
try out yourself
and see how you feel that's what my best
understanding and the number five is
only alcohol
and number five would just be drinking
Hendrix morning noon and night and this
is actually the optimal diet is if you
can drink Hendricks this music I think
the music is what's [__] it up yeah
if the music was a bit more jovial you
got that same speech this is serious
[__] though yeah this is science yeah
yeah it's all it's the five levels of
thinking yeah there you go yeah this
meme yeah five level thinking can you
just pull up like Coco melon type beat
[Music]
dude this hits man
look at this guy
it's what the [__] it looks like sorry
[Music]
see now I want to do the five levels of
thinking hey
level one good and bad level one
good and bad actually I forgot the level
sorry what's the other all right let's
stop this [__] before I [__] go off
go off
you better cut this [__] out before I
really start like rapping crazy up here
Brian has data on everything he even
built an at-home clinic for weekly
testing that's crazy a doctor's office
in your house yeah
it's like this guy's like the
quintessential like you know yeah
billionaire Tech founder yeah that just
you know over obsessed with
this now at what point in this video
does he turn the camera and go this is
my gym but he also hits the he also hits
the gym pretty hard yeah of course yeah
that boy is glazed it's freaking me out
that's that what even is this I would
wager some boys on sniffies have seen
similar sites boys
I bet a couple gang you know little
parties on sniffies have gone the same
route
I've heard that's pretty good for the
skin yeah yeah that is an anti-aging
population yeah
yeah does muscle contraction for example
if you apply to the abdomen it's the
equivalent of 20 000 sit-ups in 30
minutes instant ABS is possible have you
seen the Rick and Morty episode what
they sleepwalk and in their sleep
they're doing setups yeah yeah activity
Fitness sleep tracker blood sugar with a
CGM a poop test and then you get a
comprehensive hormone poop test
why do you say that so casually a poop
test Fitness sleep tracker blood sugar
with a CGM a poop test
he did not just look your boy in the eye
and say poop test and nobody cracked a
smile or anything a poop test a poop
test
yeah not bad yeah yeah yeah no yeah look
me in the eye say that don't laugh
see Jim
a CGM tracker [__] hmm what else
[Laughter]
there's a test that you're you're
missing
a poop test a poop test
did you get your poop tested
I'm thinking about
face
saying it like right
a poop test right
and then you get a comprehensive does he
say yeah sleep tracker blood sugar with
a CGM a poop test and then you get a
he was like
what'd you just saying
yeah yeah
like but the term is like fecal test
yeah which is not medical examination
yeah that's better than poop tests yeah
fart test yeah yeah a poopy test
he should have ripped it just vulgar a
[__] test
you got to get your turds tested a dump
swamp you gotta take a turd quiz
yeah
a dookie exam
what do you think a poop test is you
think that's just confirming whether or
not shooting in a bag
that was all right
and then the doctor calls you says do
you have do you have a moment to talk
about your test results
yeah so I I smelled this it's definitely
[__]
like oh thank God
oh I was worried
yeah it came out it was like green I
just wasn't sure I just didn't know if
it was poop or not no definitely
driving to the doctor talk like you're a
dog you gotta take a look at this
so what Brian talks about is the goal of
the autonomous self where you become a
system that just follows a protocol this
is why everything in Brian's day is
[__] horrible way yeah that's life
dude keep going let's watch his morning
routine this is yeah this is this is
routine guy yeah on yes this is exactly
what we're talking about this is a
routine guy on this is the next level
though one thousand dude bro you think
all the like
Rich you know Drop Shipping guys are
watching this going like [__]
what if he ends up being a baby
yes like what if he just takes it too
far and like he you know like bridges
that point of no return and they're like
wait your aging is reversing way faster
than we thought we can't stop it and
he's like guys
what if we did another poop test we
could do nothing
like it's too late they're like oh my
God we have to raise him again